time for some pft on yahoo sports peter
king mike florio some of the big stories
in the national football league and this
isn't top of the fold
big story but it is very significant
it's it's easy for any significant story
to get lost with everything that's
happening currently in the nfl but we
can't let this pass the moment from this
past weekend sarah fuller
playing kicker for vanderbilt callie
bronson
serving as tight ends coach for the
browns on sunday we see more and more
females involved in football
it is i think a slow-moving snowball but
the snowball is moving and it's getting
larger peter and this may not be
something that that bears obvious fruit
in the next five or ten years but boy it
sure feels like the the momentum is
building for more and more female
involvement in football to the point
where we could see a female general
manager at some point down the line and
maybe at some point there's enough
female coaches that one of them rise up
to actually be considered to be a head
coach
mike you know how sometimes we discuss
how uh you know the
minority representation in
ownership uh you know
running nfl teams you know when jason
wright got the job with the washington
football team everyone hailed it hey
this is the first time ever
that uh you know a black man
has run an nfl franchise which obviously
is a historic occasion
but i i think that we might be on the
verge of something similar in the nfl i
think it's great this weekend that you
know the first uh female player ever in
a power five game
uh
you know when sarah fuller got to kick
for vanderbilt and i think it's great
that callie bronson uh got a shot to be
the tight ends coach and austin hooper
went and scored a touchdown in that game
for cleveland uh over the weekend but i
think the name to watch in my opinion
is the name of don aponte so don aponte
for those who don't know has worked for
several nfl teams and is now
the uh
administrator of the football operations
department inside the nfl she's very
very plugged in
and and helping to run
all of the covid related stuff that is
going on in the league but she's done
more than that
she really has had her hand in almost
every aspect from cap management uh you
know to to covid uh management and
i have been told by a couple of people
in the league that
they will not be surprised to see her
get an interview to either be a gm or
club president in the next year or two
it's long overdue you ask bill parcells
you ask some of the people who have
employed donna ponte
that she definitely can do the job is
totally unintimidated uh by anybody who
just like kim ang
who got the miami marlins gm job many
stories of people in baseball you know
in intimidating ways and she just
wouldn't have it it's the same thing
with donna ponte
one of the fundamental issues in the nfl
when it comes to representation of
minorities and coaching and gm jobs is
that there is gross underrepresentation
of minorities in the ownership ranks
there are plenty of females who are
involved in ownership of nfl teams from
sheila fordham now in detroit from kim
pagula co-owner of the buffalo bills amy
adams strunk controlling owner of the
tennessee titans so
there there are female voices at the
highest levels of the sport
that i think sets the stage uh maybe
even more so than it does for you know
the growth that the nfl has been trying
to get in minority representation the
female representation becomes easier
peter when you have so many female
owners and it seems like there are more
all the time
i think the next step has to be either a
club president or a full-time position
coach exclusive position coach katie
sauer has done a great job in san
francisco i'd like to see katie sauers
being handed a high level position job
you know or cali bronson at some point
soon that to me is the next step and
getting donna ponte a high level job
with one of the teams
well our friend amy trask blazed that
path for the raiders as team president
years ago and it does seem inevitable
that someone else will be following in
her footsteps and someone will be
expanding the role of females in high
level positions with nfl teams it's just
a matter of time that's it for today's
edition of pft on yahoo sports he's
peter king i'm mike florio we'll see you
next time
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports